hello everyone
as my own life is still in somewhat of a
wild uh chaotic state
i thought that i could tell you guys a
story
it's a story that i've been thinking
about for several years and it's a story
which relates to what's going on today
in the world
and um and so you guys have been
following me some of you have been
following me now for two years
i figure you're all um ready to do your
own symbolic interpretation
go i'm going to tell you the story and
hopefully you can all come to your own
conclusions based on that
story and so the story is the story
of a medieval romance called silence
it is a lesser-known romance but it has
garnered attention recently because it
deals with certain issues
it is not the only romance with which
deals with these
subjects but this one has a particular
strength to it
which is worth mentioning it's called
the romance of silence
it is part of the arthurian romance
cycle
in the the romance of silence
we find a situation in the middle ages
where
women were not allowed to inherit land
and because women were not allowed to
inherit land
a certain nobleman when he
has a daughter he decides at some point
to raise the daughter as
a boy in order that
his land may continue on in his family
and so as the child grows
the father is forced to tell the child
whose name is silence that
we're going to say he because in the
text the the texts they do
say that silence they use the maculan
pronoun
in order to name silence and so
the the father tells his daughter
that he must not reveal
his true nature to the world and must
hide his true nature
in order for the his lineage to be able
to continue
and so in this romance silence grows up
and becomes a
knight becomes a squire
becomes several things which are
traditionally
roles that men have and is excels at
them becomes an amazing knight
who's extremely strong and gets the
attention of
the king even and so this
young knight at the age of 15 is
brought into the king's court you know
as this prodigy
who is going to uh to help the king in
his
different problems and all through the
story
there are two characters which appear
two allegorical characters
one is nature and the other is nurture
and these two characters will argue with
silence
during the entire story about whether or
not
silence should act according to her
nature or whether or not she should act
according to
this nurturing that she has received and
so the different characters they
they discuss they debate the problems
of one or the other and
uh and so the question is who is going
to win
is nature going to win or is nurture
going to win because
in terms of nurture silence is a man
but in terms of nature silence is a
woman
and so the question is who will
who will win in the end and so silence
arrives in the king's court and
immediately the king's wife the queen
becomes enamored with silence
especially seeing that silence is a
valley at night
and that silence is able to
perform several feats and so the queen
tries
to seduce silence and wants to take
silence as her lover
but silence of course refuses her
advances
one because he's an honorable knight
second
because he is a woman uh and for all
those reasons
he refuses the queen and the queen is
extremely angry with silence
she is so angry and jealous
that she accuses silence
of trying to rape her
and so she accuses the silence before
the king that
uh silence had tried to rape her and the
king is dismayed because silence is one
of his best nights
silence has acquired all this honor in
his court
and so he does not know what to do to
dishonor his court but also to
to humiliate uh himself humiliate
the the the his own entourage all of
that
he has dismayed and so the queen
has an idea there is a
legend there is this saying which is
that
merlin has fleed
into the wild lands he has become
a wild creature he has let himself
completely go
and exist as a wild man in the forest
and there is this legend which is that
merlin cannot be caught by
a man but can only be caught by the
trickery
of a woman and so the queen tells the
king
send silence out to try to catch merlin
and because he is a man he will not be
able to catch merlin
and there therefore he will be
dishonored uh
you can tell him that if he if he does
not catch
uh merlin he has to leave your court he
cannot come back he cannot be hired by
anybody
and you can destroy him in that manner
and so the king tells this to silence
and says you have to go
into the wild area and you have to catch
merlin and so silence
goes out in order to catch him
he arrives in the wild land and he
he hears of a way that maybe he can
catch merlin merlin has been living like
an animal on wild nuts
and uh and roots and he has become
covered
in hair you know he is this hairy beast
who lives out in
the uh wild he has lost all
memory of civilization all memory of
himself
and so silence decides to put
out some meat
because the human humans human beings
are
carnivorous especially if it is well
cooked
and so he puts out this meat but he also
puts out a few other traps which i'll
tell you later
he puts out this meat and and so he
hides and
merlin comes out and merlin giving in to
his nature
you know he has now nurtured himself
into being a wild man
but suddenly remembering and being
reconnected with his human
nature he devours the uh
the meat without thinking and he eats
this entire
piece of meat and he finds himself to be
extremely thirsty
and so silence has laid out something to
drink from berlin
but without but merlin does not know
that what silence has laid out
is a jar full of honey and so merlin
drinks this honey
and having drunk this honey he is even
thirstier and thirsty and thirstier and
looking out he sees something else to
drink and then he
finds this jar of milk and so he drinks
up this milk and so
having drank a jar of honey and having
drank
a jar of milk he finds himself thirstier
than
he has ever been before and so right
ahead of him is another
drink that he can have and that drink of
course is wine
and so merlin gulps the wine without
thinking
and falls into a drunken stupor
now i won't tell you the meaning but uh
i would i'm
hoping that in some of the comments you
will
try to analyze the relationship between
him remembering his nature eating meat
eating drinking honey drinking milk and
then ultimately drinking wine let's see
who can
come up with a good uh interpretation of
that
all right enough parentheses let's
continue and so
silence finds merlin in this stupor
and merlin is surprised how is it
possible
that this man has caught me but merlin
looks
at uh silence
and already begins to snicker
he begins to have a secret laugh
rise within him so silence tells merlin
that he has to bring him back
to the court and that merlin has
to uh to answer for different things
and as uh silence is bringing merlin
back to the court the people hear about
this and they start to assemble
and they start to get ready to to
receive merlin but along the way
merlin comes up and he sees this poor
man
who is walking around and he is holding
a pair of brand new shoes this this
peasant who is holding a pair of brand
new shoes
and merlin starts to laugh and merlin
starts to snicker and snicker and he's
struggling to hold it in and so he's
laughing
and silence asks him why are you
laughing why is it poor man
holding a new pair of shoes making you
laugh but but
uh merlin will not answer he will only
laugh
and so as he's going further he sees in
front of a church
a group of mendicants a group of poor
beggars
who are begging for their food who are
begging
for uh for a little bit of money
and merlin starts to laugh even more
and his laughter is louder and more
uncontrollable
and silence asks him merlin why are you
laughing why are these beggars here
in front of the church how is it that
they're making you laugh but merlin will
not
answer merlin will only laugh and his
laugh
is getting louder and more
uncontrollable and as
he gets closer and closer to the town he
walks
in front of the cemetery and he sees a
man
who is burying a young child
and next to this man burying his young
child
is a priest who is saying the prayers
and he is sensing the tomb
and then merlin loses control and he is
on the ground
holding his belly laughing and laughing
and laughing and silence is how horrible
is this
how can you laugh at how can you laugh
at this situation
what what is making you laugh in this
situation but merlin will not
tell her and all he can do is laugh
until
silence drags him back drags him back to
the court
and brings him into the presence of the
king
and so as the the as merlin enters
he enters into the court and all the
noble people and everybody
is surrounded him and the king is asking
first of all the king is
asking him you know first of all you
lied to us you told us that
only a woman could catch you and hear a
man has caught you you have
you have bear born fault false witness
you have said something which is untrue
how do you account for that
but also how is it that you laughed at
this poor man holding his shoes
how is it that you laughed at these
beggars and how is it that you laughed
at this child who died and who was being
buried by his father and incensed by the
priest
and merlin looks at the king and he
starts to laugh at the king
and he is laughing and laughing and
laughing and no one knows what's going
on
so merlin looks around and he sees
this nun who is coming and who is
accusing him on the ground and he looks
at this nun
and his laughter it just keeps going on
and he's pointing
at this nun and he's laughing at this
nun and the queen
is in rage and she's screaming how is
this possible what is this
insult and then merlin catches a glimpse
of the queen and of course
his laughter gets worse and worse even
still
and so there he is he is laughing at the
queen he is laughing at the king at this
nun he is laughing also at himself and
he is laughing
at silence as well every time silence
appears in his
in his view and so the king is getting
angry and he says merlin
you have to tell us you have to tell us
why you are laughing so this is
unacceptable
this is this is unacceptable behavior on
your part
so merlin tries to call himself tries to
call himself he says first of all tell
us
why did you laugh as you were as you
were coming back
to the uh the castle why did you laugh
at the poor man who was holding his
shoes and then
it all begins merlin moves from
a moment of laughter uncontrollable
laughter
to beginning to reveal the secrets which
are hidden
behind the appearances
he begins to show how the appearances
are concealing how the appearances are
upside down and are concealing
a secret underneath
and so he says i laughed at that man
poor man who was so proud
of his new shoes but who would die
before even reaching
his house so the king dispatches his
soldiers
and he finds the poor man who has died
on the road back to his house
so he says well then why did you laugh
at these poor beggars
who were there standing in front of the
church and so
the king so merlin says i laughed at
those beggars because
there they were begging for the tiniest
morsel
you know acting as if they were poor as
if their environment was completely
barren as if everything was desolate
around them
when in fact right under them under the
ground
was hiding a treasure of immeasurable
wealth and so they pretended that they
had nothing
that their resources were finished but
in fact they had
an infinite amount of wealth beneath
them so the king
sends out his guards and he he digs up
the the ground and he finds the treasure
which merlin had said and he sees it
merlin now until now
he has been revealing all these secrets
so finally
he says why did you laugh
at the child who who died and
whose father was bearing and the priest
was incensing him and he says
i was laughing because the father should
not have been crying
little did he know that the father was
not
the father of that child but the father
of that child was the priest
who was incensing the grave and so the
father
shouldn't should not have been mourning
the child of the priest which he
would have been forced to raise
and so then we come to the final
moments why did merlin laugh
when he was arriving in the king's court
and so then merlin says i laughed
because
i laughed at four people i laughed at
you o king
i laughed at myself i laughed at the
actually
there's five people actually i laughed
at the queen
i laughed at this nun and i also laughed
at
silence he says i laugh because
amongst all those people there are two
tricks
and there are two who are being tricked
and two of those people
should be laughed at because they are
being tricked
so the king is like enough of these
puzzles enough of your puzzles merlin
tell me straight out what is happening
and so finally merlin reveals the secret
he reveals the fact that that nun is not
a nun
that the nun is in fact a man who
is dressed as a nun in order to be
sneaky i won't use god's side's
expression
but who is acting as a sneaky
person getting into the queen's
chamber and is in fact the queen's
secret lover
and he says i also
laughed at you king because you were
being tricked in that situation
i also laughed because i was tricked i
was tricked because in fact
silence is not a man
silence is a woman and so then the king
of course
puts two and two together how is it
possible
that that silence tried to rape his wife
his silence is a woman
and so merlin said i was also laughing
at myself
because i was tricked by a woman without
even knowing it
i was brought back by a man who was in
fact a woman
and so they take the nun and they take
silence and they remove their clothing
in order to
see the truth and it says in the text
that everything was in its place
and i think that statement is the most
accurate and the best way to put it
of how merlin's laughter his
uncontrollable
laughing a trick
upon a trick this double inversion
brought about a re-establishing
of normal order
and then the king announced to silence
because he understood that the reason
why this happened was because women
did not have any place in society before
that because
that women did not were did not have
ways to participate
in their lineage and therefore the king
announces that from this day on
women will be allowed to inherit and not
only that
but of course for the story to end well
silence becomes silencia
and she now becomes the queen
and marries the king and everything
um everything finishes and everybody
lives
happily ever after and so
that is my little story
i told it to you so maybe we can see how
you all
can interpret it yourself and it also
feels nice for myself to laugh
because laughter is sometimes the best
way to find your
way out of uh chaos and tragedy
so guys i want to uh thank you again for
your attention
thank you to everybody who has been
supporting me through this crazy flood
it is still going on there is still
water in my basement
and also you know there's still water in
my street
we are hoping that in the next few days
the water will go away so that we can
start to
pump the water out of the basement and
assess
the damage but i have to be honest that
it does not
look good so thanks again and i will see
you soon
you